turning now to a growing trend across
the country okay the farm to table
movement it's also helping americans
rediscover food from bygone eras
baltimore as you know is very famous for
those crab cakes they are good but back
in its heyday the city was a culinary
mecca did you know this known for
everything from pickled oysters to being
the possible birthplace of fudge nicole
killian found one food blogger who's
digging up dishes from the past and
rediscovering the power of food to
connect people i know that's true it's
part of our series we call it a more
perfect union which aims to show that
what unites us as americans is far far
greater than what divides us
add one cup sugar
one cup of butter six eggs reading
recipes boil all well together and seal
while hot is food for kara harris's soul
how did this culinary adventure begin i
found these recipes that had maryland in
the title like maryland's white potato
pie the only way to try them was to go
ahead and make them myself when did you
find out when you tried that very first
dish i found out that i wasn't very good
at making pie crust we dished at the
paper moon diner a funky retro style
cafe in her baltimore neighborhood
where over the past decade the
self-taught cook has figured out not
only how to make pie crust but a whole
lot more
the maryland native has transformed her
foodie fascination of unearthing
hometown dishes into the blog old line
plate with a database of more than 40
thousand recipes baltimore caramel
essentially a recipe for fudge vinegar
candy maryland fried chicken deviled
crab she's taken local cookbooks dating
back decades and methodically mapped out
the origin of each recipe harris's
extensive research comes from her
collection of 200 cookbooks and long
hours at baltimore's historic pratt
library to discover and ultimately share
the history of some of america's most
iconic and long-lost foods this is a
hobby for you is it a passion i guess
both i see it as a hobby i tell people
that it's like
building model cars i want to
continually get better at it like baking
this victorian inspired rose geranium
cake from 1910. this cake sounded
interesting because it involves these
geranium leaves so there's not actually
roses in the recipe because that's what
i thought when you
yeah a lot of old recipes were flavored
with rose before vanilla caught on we're
adding spreading one cup of water
sometimes it can be a mix
of trial and error so they just contain
a little bit of extra air
[Music]
with these old recipes
they give you the biggest of
instructions and you just have to know
what to do from there
all right
[Music]
hmm this is very delicious it's very
light
here we go in other instances it's a
matter of going straight to the source
but mama know how to get on that stove
and just work it like when cara tracked
down bertha hunt to chronicle a
centuries-old family recipe for southern
maryland stuffed ham
what did you think when you first got
that call
asking for your recipe
i was shocked and this means a lot to me
it's been from generation to generation
to generation and with me with my mom
and it came down
from slavery
you must remember my great-grandmother
was a slave
i put the cabbage
the kale and the onions then i put my
seasonings you stuff it you have to wrap
it
i boiled it that's the finished product
right there
i hope it's not too hot for you i really
do
this is very flavorful
season with salt and pepper but to get a
true taste for why kara does this it's a
lot more than finding these recipes
absolutely finding the people too i
don't own the recipes but i love
connecting with people about the food
that means a lot to them
and that's the key ingredient while
boiling add a pinch of allspice a few
blades of mace for cbs mornings i'm
nicole killian in baltimore
nicole had a general had a genuine
reaction to that last thing because she
started
flavorful really good i think icing
makes everything better i was hoping
that there would be some cake on set at
some point not meant to be no not today
tomorrow some of the best recipes come
from yesteryear that's for sure
mood is so healing it makes everything
better to sit down with somebody and
have a great meal